[Música]
nueva madrugada de bombardeos israelíes
sobre gaza 50 ataques en menos de 15
minutos dejaron al menos 33 muertos en
la séptima jornada entre los últimos
objetivos estuvo la casa del líder de
hamás quien al parecer no estaba en el
lugar estos bombardeos se produjeron en
simultáneo con el lanzamiento de cohetes
desde casa
los colombianos completaron 18 días
continuos de protestas
antigubernamentales reclamando reformas
sociales políticas y el fin de la
brutalidad policial en medio de
denuncias de violencia sexual este
domingo se renuevan las negociaciones
entre el gobierno y el comité nacional
del paro
segundo día de votación en elecciones
históricas en chile donde los ciudadanos
eligen a los constituyentes que
redactarán la nueva carta magna además
de alcaldes concejales y gobernadores 15
millones de chilenos están llamados a
las urnas de los cuales más de tres
millones sufragaron ayer en la primera
jornada de elección
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 cerró blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos esta
mañana los bombardeos israelíes contra
gaza no cesan en menos de 15 minutos el
ejército israelí realizó por lo menos 50
bombardeos son la mañana del domingo
destruyendo además la residencia del
líder del grupo hamas que no estaba en
ese momento en su vivienda
los ataques se elevaron el número de
muertos en casa a 181 desde que empezó
la actual escalada bélica que alcanza
hoy su séptima jornada estos bombardeos
se produjeron en simultáneo con el
lanzamiento de cohetes desde gaza hacia
tel aviv durante la noche los detalles
con andrew amaya
se incrementa la escalada de violencia
entre israelíes y palestinos los civiles
son los más afectados los 50 bombardeos
de este domingo en la madrugada en gaza
por parte del ejército de israel y
dejaron al menos 33 muertos en 15
minutos destruyeron varias
construcciones de la ciudad incluyendo
la casa del líder del movimiento hamás y
allá así igual quien no se encontraba en
su vivienda en ese momento los
bombardeos israelíes se produjeron en
simultáneo con el lanzamiento de cohetes
desde gaza según un portavoz militar
israelí se registraron más de 130
disparos cifra que eleva a 2900 los
proyectiles lanzados a su territorio
desde el inicio de la actual escalada
bélica según la fuente unos 450 cohetes
han caído dentro del enclave y unos
1.150 han sido interceptados por el
sistema antimisiles israelí actualmente
varios equipos trabajan en el rescate de
las personas atrapadas bajo los
escombros de varios edificios
residenciales derribados en gasa con
excavadoras intentan remover los
escombros para sacar a los
sobrevivientes atrapados y los cuerpos
de los que murieron
hay un hombre vivo nuestro equipo habló
con él y nos dijo que está vivo el
equipo lo sacará y esperamos que su
hermana también esté viva y podamos
sacarla
tanto israel como el grupo hamas han
insistido en continuar los ataques un
día después de que israel destruyera un
edificio de 12 pisos en gaza que
albergaba a medios de comunicación
internacionales la ola de ataques
israelíes de este domingo ha sido la
mayor desde hace siete días cuando
empezaron los enfrentamientos
cambiamos ahora información las marchas
antigubernamentales en colombia se
acercan a las 3 semanas los
manifestantes reclaman reformas sociales
políticas y el fin de la brutalidad
policial
ahora con énfasis en las denuncias de
violencia sexual tras conocerse el
aparente suicidio de una menor de edad
después de haber sido supuestamente
agredida sexualmente por cuatro
uniformados la jornada de ayer
transcurrió en calma en varias ciudades
del país con masivas concentraciones de
los colombianos este domingo en la tarde
se reanudarán las negociaciones entre el
gobierno y el comité nacional del paro
rosa pérez con más detalles
en el día número 18 de paro nacional en
colombia el epicentro de las protestas
se trasladó a bogotá la capital el
monumento a los héroes en el norte de la
ciudad fue el lugar de la masiva
congregación el descontento que estalló
por la reforma tributaria del gobierno
duque suma nuevos argumentos la
brutalidad de la fuerza pública
protagoniza la indignación entre las
denuncias de violencia las de violencia
sexual hoy salimos a las calles porque
estamos cansados de este autoritarismo
de este régimen que nos responde con
represión no nos escucha quienes se
reúnen con el gobierno tampoco nos
representan tenemos una agenda clara
desde las calles una reforma policial
que se tumbe el régimen y la reforma a
la salud y cómo responde el gobierno
violando a nuestras hermanas masacrando
nos y este es un claro ejemplo del
descontento social la presunta agresión
sexual de la menor de edad
allison meléndez por parte de cuatro
uniformados que llevó a la adolescencia
a suicidarse encendió el viernes las
calles de popayán donde murió un joven
supuestamente por el impacto de una
granada aturdidora de la policía en el
cuello
la misma noche fue incendiado el
edificio de medicina legal incidente que
el gobierno en marco en su narrativa de
que las guerrillas están detrás de las
protestas los cuatro agentes implicados
en la detención de meléndez fueron
apartados temporalmente del cuerpo según
la policía además el fiscal general
anunció a la investigación del caso
la ong temblores registra al menos 16
casos de violencia sexual desde el
inicio de las protestas el 28 de abril
lo que piden muchos de los manifestantes
ya no son medidas disciplinarias
puntuales sino una reforma profunda de
la fuerza pública un punto sobre la mesa
de negociación que se iniciará este
domingo entre gobierno y comité de paro
seguimos en américa del sur el gobierno
de venezuela anunció que trabaja con el
comité internacional de la cruz roja
para generar las condiciones necesarias
que ayuden a liberar a los ocho
militares secuestrados el pasado 23 de
abril presuntamente por parte de las
disidencias de la ex guerrilla de las
farc el anuncio llegó en medio de las
críticas que reciba el ejecutivo
venezolano por no haberse pronunciado
sobre este hecho en la última semana
después de que fuera denunciado el
domingo pasado por la ong de derechos
humanos
y más de 3 millones de chilenos
depositaron ayer sábado su voto en los
históricos comicios constituyentes una
situación inédita en la historia del
país que celebra estas elecciones en dos
días para evitar aglomeraciones en medio
de la pandemia de kobe 19 son 155
ciudadanos con paridad de género que
redactarán la nueva carta magna que
reemplace al actual vigente desde la
dictadura militar de augusto pinochet
algo inédito en el mundo y que
convertirá chile en el primer país en
tener una constitución escrita de manera
paritaria casi 40 mil chilenos pueden
votar desde el extranjero según cifras
de 2017 sin embargo en esta elección
constituyente no pueden hacerlo nuestra
periodista en parís dedicada olavarría
conversó con dos chilenas que llegaron
en diferentes épocas a francia un país
que cuenta con una importante comunidad
del país sudamericano
esta casa perteneció a la misión de
francia que eran los curas obreros
ha albergado del 73 al 87 un flyer de
acogida para los residentes
latinoamericanos en esta casona cerca de
parís vivió la isla cuando con 12 años
llegó a francia en 1982 huyendo como
otros 15 mil chilenos de la dictadura de
pinochet
cuando comenzó el estallido sino a la
asamblea de chilenos en francia que se
hizo eco de las reivindicaciones en
chile los exiliados siempre hemos
seguido luchando estas elecciones el
gobierno negoció igual que el pacto que
hicieron con pinochet a la gente que se
presenta como independiente sin partido
prácticamente no tiene ninguna chance de
ganar entonces tienes como
obligatoriamente que inscribirte a un
partido y la gente que salió a la calle
salió a decir justamente que no quieren
más partidos ha causado tanto nato que
es agua también le trabaja en un colegio
parisino y lo francia estuviera un
doctorado en filosofía hace cinco años
antes de la pandemia participaba
activamente también en la asamblea de
chilenos en parís
el estallido social me encontraba con
francia y tampoco puede restar me de
manifestar mi compromiso y mi intención
con que chile cambie realmente a nivel
la estructura que miles se contenta con
seguir la actualidad de chile a la
distancia no puede hacer nada más ya que
los chilenos en el extranjero no sólo
podrán votar este domingo al no
constituir un distrito electoral con
representantes elegidos estamos
profundamente ligados a chile nuestra
familia nuestros amigos e incluso mis ex
estudiantes viven en chile y me gustaría
que ellos pudiesen vivir de verdad en un
estado democrático que permitiera
condiciones sociales básicas de
existencia también hay que entender que
los procesos de elección no son las
únicas formas en las que se pueda
manifestar la participación al
compromiso político su compromiso de ser
profesora aquí se familiariza con un
sistema de educación pública de calidad
una de las demandas del estallido que
espera ver algún día realizada en chile
y es que precisamente en francia hay a
más de 20 millones de personas se han
recibido al menos una dosis de la vacuna
contra el coi 19 de cara a la reapertura
de restaurantes y sitios de actividad
cultural todavía hay dudas sobre cuánto
tiempo dura la inmunidad para aquellos
vacunados o si pueden seguir expandiendo
el virus pero eso es importante un
importante paso hacia la recuperación de
la nueva normalidad de ambos
mientras francia se prepara para un
relajamiento significativo de las
restricciones la vacunación en el país
ha alcanzado un objetivo clave
el presidente macrón se dirigió a
twitter para anunciar que 20 millones de
personas es decir alrededor del 30 por
ciento de la población han recibido ya
una primera dosis la noticia llega días
antes de la reapertura de las terrazas
museos y comercios no esenciales y
cuando las autoridades sanitarias
reportan una nueva desaceleración del
número de casos más de 4000 personas
todavía están siendo tratadas en un cis
pero ese número está muy por debajo del
pico de seis mil en marzo
este llamado boom on the sun foto
obviamente este es un momento muy
importante para todo el país porque abre
y refuerza las perspectivas de finalizar
la crisis de perspectiva de softtek y
ser expertos afirman que aquellos que
estén totalmente vacunados deberían
permanecer inmunes durante al menos ocho
meses
decimos que ocho meses porque esta es la
duración de los estudios más largos que
se han llevado a cabo eso no quiere
decir que la inmunidad no vaya a durar
más simplemente quiere decir que no
tenemos estudios más allá de eso
estudios sugieren que aquellos que se
contagian tras ser vacunados tienen
menos posibilidades de contagiar a otros
university componentes de profesor si
cuando estás vacunado tienes anticuerpos
que te protegen de contraer una
enfermedad fuerte y también de un nivel
alto de replicación viral un costo el
gobierno espera haber inoculado 30
millones de primeras dosis para mitad de
junio para esa fecha los restaurantes
podrán atender clientes en interiores y
los gimnasios estarán abiertos para
finales de junio el actual toque de
queda deberá retirarse junto con la
mayoría de las medidas de cuarentena aún
en vigor y continuamos con más noticias
de la pandemia de kobe 19 en el mundo
colombia registró 530 muertes por 19na
su últimas 24 horas el máximo récord
desde que comenzó la pandemia la cifra
más elevada la tuvo bogotá que está en
crisis hospitalaria por el tercer pico
de la pandemia y tiene su sistema
hospitalario colapsado desde hace varios
días por lo que pacientes graves están
siendo remitidos a otras ciudades
argentina superó las 70 mil muertes
porque hoy 19 este sábado notificar 400
fallecimientos en las últimas 24 horas
el país atraviesa un vertiginoso aumento
de los casos con creciente del nivel de
ocupación de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos del gobierno extendió hasta
el 21 de mayo mayores restricciones en
el área de buenos aires y su periferia
intenso pero este domingo las 4.000
muertes diarias por coronavirus y
continuar registrando el número de
contagios más elevado del mundo a pesar
de que la tendencia apunto a la baja con
estos nuevos datos el país ha
contabilizado ya 24 con 26 millones de
contagios se convirtiendo al país
asiático en el segundo más afectado del
mundo en términos absolutos por la
pandemia
y cambiamos ahora información en los
museos lo son los museos musicales los
teatros y el sector de las artes en
londres en inglaterra son finalmente el
telón tras un cierre de forzado por
cuenta de esta pandemia uno de los
regresos más esperados a la escena es el
bailarín mexicano isaac hernández
aclamado en todo el mundo
isaac hernández quien fue reconocido en
el 2018 como el mejor bailarín del mundo
novela con publicó hace casi dos años en
un año normal habría tenido más de 100
funciones en todo el mundo pero la
pandemia lo obligó a saltar a la
incertidumbre
y se refiere sus extenuantes ensayos
antes de una función que regresaron con
una prenda doble
creo que es lo que nos está costando
trabajo ahora
para sentirnos cómodos otra vez en el
escenario así como las artes y todo en
el país el ballet se ha transformado por
la pandemia una de las secuelas más
grandes de los encierros ha sido la
física me volví a doler el cuerpo como
hace años donde dolía porque yo llevaba
los últimos cinco años bailando casi más
de 100 funciones al año entonces mi
físico estaba entrenado de una manera
muy especial el regreso al escenario
para la estrella del english national
ballet será con apenas 600 espectadores
en vez de miles con una actuación de
life and faith de vasili grossman es
sobre la segunda guerra mundial y lo que
trataba de capturar el coreógrafo es la
esencia del libro que es al final
en los actos de amabilidad que pueden
suceder en los momentos más oscuros de
la humanidad y dar un poco de esperanza
también al futuro si saque extraño su
público otro encuentro pendiente es en
méxico se decrete mis padres son unas
personas muy fuertes entre siempre
pienso en ellos y en el tiempo que
estamos perdiendo juntos al final de
cuentas de sexo que normalmente tengo la
posibilidad de ir a méxico con el
regreso del barrio de londres vuelve la
magia del arte que tanto hace falta
así de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continua con nosotros supone
mañana de domingo
[Música]